[Musique]
l'arme d'efforts c'est le titre d'une
création artistique et citoyenne
présenter l académie des dalons du
bernica ce vendredi 5 route six
volontaires de la promotion 27 ont
construit un projet autour du thème
sensible des violences intrafamiliales
l'alarme-eau souhaité la violence faite
aux femmes mais comme la pointure
voilà
on a englobé du ca en faisant
intrafamiliales c'est un message pour
pour les personnes en fait qu'ils ont à
faire une petit pas un cycle de la
violence ça peut dans les étapes on va
dire avec là que ça commence et comme ça
les gens ils vont pouvoir aussi un plus
va voir où ils sont et s'ils sont dans
ce stade là de commencer à en parler ou
même de parler en famille au final ça va
commencer à les en fait
si jeune femme souhaite sensibiliser
l'opinion publique sur l'importance de
cette cause et diffuser les informations
plus grand nombre
à ce que ça venait du canada des signes
comme ça c'est pour appeler à l'aide en
grosses sommes à une personne comme ça
dans la rue on sait que ben c'était de
lancer chez elle elle a besoin d'être ça
n'a pas duré angélina plusieurs rues
truc aussi
on a su aussi qu'il y avait le pouvoir
ici pour la réunion mais un point et
puis pourquoi sa mosquée
masque 19 on va la formation du havre
est fumasse spécial claude calme et
responsable du site de l'académie des
dalons au bernica mis en avant le
travail des équipes de ceux qui ont
contribué à la réussite de ce projet et
a déjà toute l'équipe éducative
pédagogique qui les accompagnent sur la
définition de leurs de leurs idées
et puis ensuite il ya effectivement
des intervenants donc là on a un ancien
volontaire de l'académie de la langue
qui maintenant à sa société qui réalise
des films avec nous
on avait on a eu soul city avec nous on
a eu des artistes comme gaël est
toujours banni l'idée c'est se mettre au
service d'une idée et l'amener le plus
loin possible avec les volontaires pour
qu'elle puisse elle
montré tout leur potentiel de création
et d'engagement la matinée s'est achevée
par des échanges entre les volontaires
et leurs invités qui à l'unanimité ont
salué la qualité de la création
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
easy rider sans danger
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]